ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครับ 5 สวัสดีครับน้องเรียม
สวัสดีครับนักเรียนสวัสดีครับวันนี้ค่ะ
เรียนอาม่าเรียนภาษาไทยกับเทียบที่กับ
น้องริวโอเคเขาผมวันนี้วันนี้เรามาเรียน
ภาษาไทยกันนะครับวันอะไรครับวันนี้
วันนี้วันจันทร์ได้ครับอ่าวันนี้วัน
จันทร์นี่นะไปติอาร์ติสต์เปิดปฏิทินมาลัย
ฮะคนที่ฮิตปฏิทินปฏิทินแล้วแกวันนี้วัน
จันทร์หน้าวันจันทร์นะครับไงค่ะวันจันทร์
วันจันทร์วันจันทร์ที่เท่าไหร่ครับวันนี้
วันที่เท่าไหร่ครับ
วันที่
15 ขอวันที่ 15 นะครับอ่าวันนี้วัน
จันทร์ที่ 15 โอเควันจันทร์ที่หัวหน้า
แล้วเดือนนี้เดือนนี้เดือนอะไรครับ
เดือนนี้เดือน
พฤศจิกายนเดือนนี้เดือน
พฤศจิกายนว้าวเดือนพฤศจิกายนแล้วปีปีคศ
อะไรครับ
ขอศ.
2521 พ.ศ
2020 เอ็ดโอเคแล้วปีพตพตอะไรครับ
ข้อ
2564 ค่ะโอเคปีพศ 2560  4-5 เรามาเรียน
ภาษาไทยกันโอเคโอเคโอเคแล้วตอนนี้เรียน
ภาษาไทยกันตอนกี่โมงครับ
ข้างนี้
10:00 นขอคุณศิริมามอง 14 นาทีมีตรงนี้
10 โมงสิบสี่นาทีนะครับห้าสิบโมงสิบสี่
นาทีแป้งกลางวันหรือกลางคืนครับ
เป็นกลางวันค่ะหน้าเป็นกลางวันนะครับ
10:14 นาทีเป็นกลางวัน
5 เป็นตอนเช้าใช่ไหมตอนเช้าใช่โอเค
เออตอนเช้า 10:00 เรียนภาษาไทยกัน
วันนี้วันนี้เราเรียนเรื่องอะไรกันดิ
เรียนเรื่องอะไรครับ
วันนี้เราเรียนกันเรื่องที่มี
อันนี้ค่ะอ๋อ
อันนี้เป็น
อะไรครับสี่เหลี่ยมศิริเดี๋ยวเป็นอะไร
ครับรูปอะไรครับอัด
สดหมายใช่ไหมครับจดหมาย
มีจดหมายอ่ามีจดหมายแท้ลจดหมายจดหมายจะมา
มาที่บ้านเรามาที่บ้านเราได้ยังไงครับ
จดหมายมาได้ยังไง
ก็ต้องมี
บุรุษไปรษณีย์
บุรุษไปรษณีย์หมายถึง
อ่ะอ๋อเป็นคนคนที่ส่งส่งจดหมายอ่ะคนที่
เอาจดหมายมาให้เอาจดหมายมาให้เราเอา
จดหมายมาให้ถ้าครัวตี้กลัวที่จะส่งจดหมาย
ไปให้น้องเรียมเปลี่ยนที่จะส่งจดหมายมา
ให้น้องเรียนต้องเอาไปให้ไปรษณีย์ให้
บุรุษไปรษณีย์ใช่ไหมครับขอบุรุษไปรษณีย์
ก็จะเอาจดหมายไปให้น้องเรียม
คะใช่ครับโอเควันนี้เราเป็นนึงบุรุษ
ไปรษณีย์อ่ะโอเค 5 เป็นคนส่งจดหมายอ้านี่
ครับเฮียตี๋มีรูปรูปของบุรุษไปรษณีย์
บุรุษไปรษณีย์เป็นผู้หญิงหรือผู้ชายครับ
บุรุษไปรษณีย์เป็นผู้ชายเป็นผู้ชายอ่ะพี่
อาร์ตี้เปียตีกอเป็นผู้ชาย
บุรุษไปรษณีย์ก็เป็นผู้ชายผู้ช้าโอเคอ้า
นี่ไงบุรุษไปรษณีย์ถืออะไรอยู่ครับถือ
อะไรหรือ
จดหมายอ๋ออ๋อถือจดหมาย
บุรุษไปรษณีย์ถือสดหมาย
โป้หลุดไปรษณีย์เอาจดหมายมาส่งให้ช่าง
ครับมาให้
น้าโอเคโอเคแล้วค่ะแล้วอันนี้อันนี้อัน
นี้อะไรครับ
ตู้
ตู้ไปรษณีย์ใช่ไหมคะอ๋ออ๋ออันนี้เป็นตู้
ไปรษณีย์
ตู้ไปรษณีย์ที่เอาไว้ใส่ใส่จดหมาย
ใส่จดหมายกล่องกล่องรับจดหมายขออ๋อเป็น
ตู้ไปรษณีย์หรือเป็นกล่องรับจดหมายเหมือน
กันใช่ไหมครับเหมือนกัน
เหมือนกันอ่าเป็นอาตู้ไปรษณีย์หรือว่าตู้
จดหมายกล่องรับจดหมายก็ได้ใช่ไหมครับอ๋อ
ได้ค่ะอ้าแล้วก็เปลี่ยนที่เห็นในรูปนี้ใน
รูปนี้จะมีบุรุษไปรษณีย์
มีจดหมาย
มีตู้ไปรษณีย์แล้วมีอะไรอีกครับมีอะไร
ครับ
เรียงเห็นหมาอ๋อมีหมาในรูปมีด้วยหมาอ๋อ
อ่อนี่ไงมีไงหมาหมา
ใช่ค่ะหมากำลังไฟดูว่าเกาะใช่ไหมเกาะรั้ว
หมากำลังเกาะนี่มากำลังเกาะเกาะเกาะรั้ว
รั้วครับรั้วรั้วก็คืออันนี้ค่ะอ๋ออันนี้
นี่คือรั้วใช่ไหมนี่รู้ว่าอั้ว
พ่อหมากำลังเกาะเกาะรั้วอ้าโอเคโอเคมาก็
โทรหามาก็รั้วแล้วมาทำอะไรอยู่ครับตอนนี้
ทำอะไรอีกเพียงดีนะหากำลังกำลังหาอ่าหมา
กำลังอ่ะๆถูกเพราะว่าขวาอะไรครับ
ครูแล้วมาเอาด้วยเห่าๆน้องเรียมเห่าๆๆๆ
โรงเรียนมเสียงทำเสียงเหมือนหมาใช่มะเห่า
หมาเห่าห้องๆโอเคหมาเห่าห้องห้องหมาเห่า
ใครครับเอาใครมาเห่าบุรุษไปรษณีย์
หมาเห่าบุรุษไปรษณีย์
ให้ค่ะ
โอเคหมาเห่าบ้านนี้บ้านนี้มีหมามีหมาหา
ใช้ครับหน้าแล้วหมาก็เห่าเห่าบุรุษ
ไปรษณีย์โอเคใคร
หน้าอ้านี้ครับถ้าต่อไปอะไรครับบทใบสนี
ใส่เสื้อ
ใส่กางเกงสีอะไรคะบุรุษไปรษณีย์ใส่เสื้อ
สีน้ำเงินอ้าใส่กางเกงสีน้ำเงินชายครับ
มีพวกด้วยค่ะอ่าใช่นี่บุรุษไปรษณีย์ใส่
หมวกด้วยหมวกสีน้ำเงิน
ครับโอ้แล้วตอนนี้ตอนนี้
ตอนนี้พี่ HD เห็นเสียงเพลงไหมคะได้ยิน
เสียงเพลงก็ไม่ได้ยิน
พ่อไม่ได้ยินโรงเรียนเปิดเพลงด้วยเหรอ
ครับเปิดเพลงไหม
เพลงอยู่ข้างๆบ้างก็มีเพลงอยู่ข้างหลัง
แต่ควรเพียงตีไม่ได้ยินอ่าโอเคแต่ตอนนี้
ตอนนี้ไปรษณีย์ไปรษณีย์กำลังตกใจตกใจ
อกใจก็หมาใจ
หมาตัวนี้กัดใช่ไหมกาดบุรุษไปรษณีย์ขอ
กาด
น้าตอนนี้บุรุษไปรษณีย์ตกใจเพราะว่าหมา
กัดหน้าหมาวิ่งออกมาวิ่งออกมาจากในบ้าน
ใช่ไหมว่า 5 วิ่งออกมาจัดหน้ามีหมากี่ตัว
ครับในรูปนี้
มีหมา 2 ตัวค่ะก็มีหมา 2 ตัวนี่หมา 1 หมา
2 ตัวโอเคหมาตัวเล็กตัวเล็กน่ะตัวนี้ตัว
เล็กกาจกาจน่ากัดไปรษณีย์
ข้างเกงกางเกงอ่าอากาศกางเกงโอเคส่วนหมา
ตัวนี้อ๋ออ๋อกัดไปที่กางเกงแล้วโอเคไป
สะนีไปรษณีย์ตกใจหมากัดกางเกงน้องเรียม
กลัวไหมกลัวหมาจัดไหมกลัวไหมกลัวค่ะกลัวๆ
เฮียตีกอล์ฟกลัวหมากัดห่า
ไปรษณีย์บุรุษไปรษณีย์ก็กลัวเห็นการ True
เหมือนกันได้เนื้อหาแล้วเพิ่งไปรษณีย์ทำ
ยังไงคะบุรุษไปรษณีย์ก็คิดคิดคิดว่าจะทำ
ยังไงไม่ให้หมากัดเพราะว่าบุรุษไปรษณีย์
ไม่ชอบไม่ชอบโดนหมากัดได้รุ่นไปรษณีย์ก็
นี่รุ่นไปรษณีย์ก็เลยไปที่นี่ครับไปที่
ไปที่ที่นี่หน้าที่นี่เป็นที่ไหนครับอ้า
โรงเรียนปูไหมเห็นไหมที่นี่ที่ไหนที่ไหน
ร้านขายอาหารขอ
เป็นร้านขายอาหารหมาใช่นี่มีอาหารหมาอยู่
เยอะเลยมีอะไรบ้างครับ
มีกระดูกอ๋อมีกระดูก
5 นี่นี้มีกระดูกอาไม่เคยคือหมากระดูก
สำหรับหมาให้อยากกินหมาชอบหมาชอบกิน
กระดูกใช่ไหมครับอ่าแค่หมาชอบอ่ะเฮียตี้
ไม่ชอบพี่ไม่กินฮ่าๆเห*้ยจริงไม่กินไม่
กินลูกกินปลาแล้ว
น้องเรียมกินกระดูก
ไงค่ะไม่เกี่ยวไม่กินอ่าโอเคแต่หมาหมากิน
กระดูกนะอ่าแล้วบุรุษไปรษณีย์บุรุษ
ไปรษณีย์มาทำอะไรมาทำอะไรที่ร้านขายอาหาร
หมาครับ
มาซื้ออ๋ออ๋อมาซื้อ
มาซื้อกระดูกมากระดูกซื้ออาหารหมา
โอเคซื้ออาหารหมาไปทำอะไรครับอ่ะ
จะเอาไปให้
ให้หมาอ๋อหมอนี้บุรุษไปรษณีย์เอากระดูกมา
แล้วเอากระดูกไปให้หมาอ้าให้หมาโอเคอ่า
ตอนนี้มาเป็นไงครับหมาเห่าไหมหมาเห่าไม่
ต้องหาไม่เห่าอ๋ออ๋อไม่เห่าแล้วไม่เห่า
แล้ว
อ่อนดีจังเพราะว่าหมาหมาเห็น
เห็นกระดูกกระดูกก็หมาอยากกินอยากกินหน้า
มาอยากกินกระดูกยังเกมาชอบชอบกระดูกใช่
ไหมหาให้ค่ะกระดูกโอเคๆเฮียตีไม่ชอบและดู
แอบมาหาซ้อขอเบอร์เก
บุรุษไปรษณีย์อีเอากระดูกให้ขอ
ให้หมาให้มาหมาชอบกระดูกหมาชอบบุรุษ
ไปรษณีย์ด้วยอ้ามาชอบบุรุษไปรษณีย์ด้วยหา
ตอนนี้หมาไม่เห่าและมาชอบบุรุษไปรษณีย์
หาแล้วนะครับก็ดีดี
เพราะว่าหมาไม่กัดได้ทีนี้หมาไม่กัดแล้ว
เพราะว่าหมาชอบกูไปสนีม้าชอบกระดูกแล้ว
หมาก็ชอบบุรุษไปรษณีย์ด้วยชอบกระดูกก็ชอบ
หลุดไปรษณีย์อ่ะมาก็เลยไม่เห่าไม่กัดไม่
กัดด้วย
นะโอเคโอเคว่ะว้าวดีจังที่นี่พูดไปรษณีย์
ก็ซองจดหมาย
ง่าย 5 ส่งจดหมายได้
ไอ้หน้าหมาไม่กัดหมาไม่เห่านะครับ
โอเคอ้านี้ครับในรูปนี้เป็นยังไงครับมี
หมาหลายตัวเลยแน่มีหมาอยู่ 3 ตัวมีหมา 3
ตัวอะตัวนี้1ตัว2ตัว
3ตัว
หมา 3 ตัวไม่กัดไม่กัดที่กางเกงนะอ่าไม่
เห่าด้วย
เติมตามท่อเดินเดินเดินอะไรนะครับเดินตาม
ตามท่อเดินตามบุรุษไปรษณีย์
เดินหมาเดิน
อามาทุกตัวเดินเดินตามบุรุษไปรษณีย์อ่า
โอเคเดินตามทำไมครับทำไมหมาเดินตามนี้
เอ๊ะทำไมหมาเดินตามสูตรไปรษณีย์มี
กระดูกบุรุษไปรษณีย์มีกระดูกหมาเดินตาม
พร้อมหมาชอบชอบกระดูกอ๋ออ๋อมาชอบกระดูก
นี้ถ้าไม่แคร์แค่รุ่นไปรษณีย์มีกระดูก
เถอะครับเรียงสงสัยว่าหมาหมา
ออกจากบ้านออกจากบ้านมายังไง
ตอบกลับบ้านมา
baat คิดว่าคิดว่าหมากระโดด
โดดข้ามหมาอยู่ในบ้านหมากระโดด
กระโดดข้ามรั้ว
ข้ามรั้วอะนี้เป็นรั้วกระโดดข้ามรั้วออก
แม่
สาน้อยอาเราว่าเตรียมเห็นรั้วติดอยู่ติด
อยู่ใช่ไหมอ่ะโอเคได้ครับอาหมาเปิดรั้ว
ได้ไหมเปิดตัวตรงนี้
หมาเปิดรั้วไม่ได้ก็มาเปิดรั้วไม่ได้อ้ะ
หมาก็เลยกระโดดข้ามออกมากระโดดกระโดดข้าม
รั้วโอเคอ่าแต่แล้วเวลาที่เวลาที่ตอนที่
น้องเรียมจะเข้าบ้าน
น้องเรียมกระโดดข้ามหรือโรงเรียนมเปิด
เปิดประตูครับ
เตรียมเปิดสอ
555 เราเรามีมือที่มือ
เราใช้มือเปิดประตูหนีกลับตรงนี้แล้วเปิด
ประตูได้หน้าแต่หมาหมาๆไม่มีมือ Marc
เปิดประตูไม่เป็น
ได้ครับมาก็เลยต้องก็เลยกระโดดโอ้หมา
กระโดดสู่สูงไหมครับสูงไหม
สูง 5 หมากกระโดดสูงกระโดดจากตรงนี้ถึง
ตรงนี้โอ้โหหมากระโดดสูง 5 พี่อาร์ตี้
เพื่อตีกระโดดไม่สูงกระโดดไม่สูงพี่ที่
อาจจะกระโดดได้แค่นี้
ไม่ครามพี่กระโดดเปิดดูๆพี่ต้องเปิดหน้า
ต้องเปิดประตูเข้าไปที่ไม่กระโดดอ่ะโอ๊ย
หนอโอเคหมาทุกตัวก็เลยรวมชอบครับ
ใช่ค่ะเตรียมเห็นบุรุษไปรษณีย์หนวด
บุรุษไปรษณีย์มีหนวดหรอใช่ครับมีหนวดเออ
เดี๋ยวนะเดี๋ยวพี่อาร์ตี้ให้พี่ตีวาดรูป
หนวด
ก็มีอันนี้อุดไปรษณีย์ใช่ไหมบุรุษ
ไปรษณีย์มีตา
มีตามีจมูกมีป่านะแล้วหนวดหนวดอยู่ตรงไหน
ครับนวดอยู่ตรงนี้อ้าเอาหนวดแบบไหนครับ
ด่วน
เปลี่ยนอีกวาดรูปหนวดเหมือนไหมเนี่ยเลยนะ
เหมือนมั้ยเหมือนหนวดไหม of ปากกาเฮียตี้
โอเคอ่าเป็นหนวดอันนี้เป็นหนวดอ๋อตรงนี้
ตรงนี้คือหนวดใช่ไหมครับแก้เครียดดีเคย
เห็นเคยเห็น
เคยเห็นคนมีตรงนี้ด้วยครับ
อ๋ออ๋อตรงนี้
อาหารตรงนี้อยากว่านี้เรียกอะไรครับอ๋อ
เราเราเข้าอยู่ตรงนี้ใช่ไหม
เหล่าฮาตรงนี้เป็นคราวอ่าส่วนตรงนี้เป็น
หนูหนวดหมวดอ๋ออ๋อเป็นหนวดหน้าบุรุษ
ไปรษณีย์มีหนูหนวดอาอามีหนวดรถไปรษณีย์
ไม่มีคราวมีไหมไม่มีเราเปลี่ยนที่ใส่คราว
ให้วาดคราวให้บุรุษเป็น
โอเคบุรุษไปรษณีย์มีข่าวเข้าสีอะไรครับ
เราสีดำอ่ะคราวสีดำใช้ครับหนวดหนวดสีอะไร
ครับอ่ะหมอนวดสีดำโอเคอาร์มเหมือนผมนิผม
ผมสีอะไรครับ
ผมสีดำผมสีดำโอเคโอเคโอเคว้าวอ้าวันนี้
เราเรียนเรื่องต่อบุรุษไปรษณีย์บุรุษ
ไปรษณีย์มาทำอะไรครับมาทำอะไรที่บ้านเรา
ส่งจดหมายบุรุษไปรษณีย์มาซองจดหมายโอเค
ใช่ค่ะพี่แอดตี้คะครับมีจดหมายแล้วเรียม
ก็เคยเห็นบุรุษไปรษณีย์มาส่งพัสดุขอพัด
สดุเป็นกล่องใช่ไหมเป็นกล้องทัศนาใช่ครับ
ใช่ครับรุ่นไปรษณีย์ส่งกล่องส่งพัสดุ
กล่องพัสดุและส่งจดหมาย
จ่าหน้าชายครับเต็มหน้าบวมไปรษณีย์ส่ง
พัสดุแล้วก็ส่งจดหมายด้วยนะครับใช้ค่ะและ
นี่ก็คือวันนี้ที่เราได้เรียนรู้กันไปนะ
ครับเป็นจดหมายนะครับเป็นบุรุษไปรษณีย์
อ่า
แล้วเดี๋ยวอ้ามีหมาก 5 ๆๆ
น้องเรียมโรงแรมบอกลานักเรียนให้หน่อย
ได้ค่ะแล้วเจอกับพี่อาร์ตี้กับเรียมได้
ใหม่ในครั้งหน้านะคะค่ะเขาจะลืมเจอกัน
ใหม่กดกด like แล้วก็กด Subscribe นะคะ
เอาช่องที่เห็นสิเบอร์ไทยด้วยนะคะได้ทราย
เขาจ้องคอม frenzel ไทยอยู่ข้างบนนี้นะ
ครับอย่าลืมไปกดให้ด้วยกด like กด
Subscribe แล้วเดี๋ยวคราวหน้าเรากลับมา
กลับมาเรียนด้วยกันใหม่กลับมาเจอกันหัว
หน้าโอเควันนี้เบียร์ที่จับน้องเรียมลา
ไว้ก่อนครับลาไปก่อนแล้วค่ะสวัสดีค่ะ
สวัสดีครับน้องเรียนบ๊ายบายค่ะพี่อาร์ตี้
ไอ้ฟายน์